[Music]
on today's show we talked to a mom whose
young son is having outbursts of rage
and she doesn't know what to do we
talked to the father of a special needs
son who just wants to be a good dad when
we talk to a young mom whose husband
keeps making sexual jokes around the
kids whoa stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john delony show
man so good to talk to you and see you
hope you're doing well it is an icy
snowy mess
here in nashville and it is beautiful
like
like i've never seen before and dicey
how was it getting to work this morning
guys
we got there it was the parking lot that
was tricky yeah i went to pull in the
parking lot and i just slid right past
the whole entrance and just kept on
going man my neighborhood out in the
woods
man it was i need a tractor i need a
tractor we need to listen we need to
send this podcast to more of your
friends
and uh subscribe to it on the tubes so
that we get more money so i can get a
tractor that's what we need do you guys
want tractors
austin you look great in a tractor so if
you had a tractor you may do better in
the snow but that means you get to work
like 45 minutes late instead of five
minutes instead of 10 minutes yeah well
played i see what you did there
but you wouldn't slip
i would go
11 miles an hour all right let's this is
gonna get sideways
did you notice james i'm trying not to
say mean things anymore
i
yes i've noticed the past two days
you've done great
it's little wins james it's little wins
life changed one moment at a time let's
go to ellen and desmoin yes iowa and des
moines what's up ellen
hey dr john how are you
i'm good thanks for having me on you bet
sorry for being late man it is
treacherous getting out of my
neighborhood this morning
no problem we had all the snow this
weekend so
i'm used to it yeah y'all are used to it
yeah this texas kid's still figuring it
out so what's up how can i help you this
morning
so i have a six-year-old son and he's
strong-willed he's overall well-behaved
but he has these outbursts of rage and
anger at home
where he'll throw and push things he'll
scream and hit and i just don't know
what to do
oh man what have you all tried
everything
it feels like um when it happens we've
tried
we go through i go through like a
checklist in my mind i've tried to
i give him some space alone
but then i'm like well i don't know if
that's the right decision i've tried to
sit down just with him away from his
siblings and talk to him
we've
we've tried
like i hate to admit it we've tried
spanking i feel like we've tried
everything
to like de-escalate the situation sure
and i don't know what to do how many how
many other kids you got
we have three we have a three and a half
year old and an almost eight month old
and then how old is
this sick
so this one's the oldest he's the oldest
yes oh okay
i just i said that kind of dismissively
i
i don't so
uh well i'm writing a note to myself
here all right so
um here's how i i kind of work through
here's not kind of here's my model for
working through these situations okay
okay it's environment
the model
language and then medical
okay
so i always want to keep a
keep an antenna up if you will for
something medical is there some sort of
disorder is there some sort of i don't
even say disorders of some sort of
adaptation is there brain issues right
those are rare but they're there okay
i put that last because i want to try
some other things up here first the
first would be environment and when you
tell me that you have a six-year-old and
then you have a three-year-old and an
eight-month-old my first picture without
even meeting this this is a boy girl
boy this this beautiful little boy
is
he was everything and now he's at the
bottom
yep is that fair
yes that's okay very fair and that
that's not anybody's fault that's not a
fault thing that's just an a life thing
is
somebody's got diapers and somebody
needs to eat and you can bathe yourself
go bathe yourself
and then it comes out as a nuclear
reactor right
yeah um
is there any place where he's learned
this
yeah i mean i would admit that in the
past i haven't always handled situations
the best
um what does that mean are you an
exploder
yes okay yeah okay what about your
husband
uh
somewhat not as much he's not his job is
more demanding so he's not always home
when the situations happen so it's more
me that explodes okay
partly because i'm home alone right
right so what type of pressure
um or what type of
support does he provide when he is at
home
he is really great about doing anything
i ask him to do if i tell him like
here's what i think we need to do and we
need to do a b and c and like lay out an
exact plan and he he'll do it without
you know support me no matter what it's
just a little bit harder when i'm trying
to figure out okay what do we need to do
but i don't have as much support so he's
less of a supporter
in in terms of planning caring taking
initiative
and he's he's a doer he's got strong
arms right yes yeah he'll lift the box
that you you point him and tell him to
lift i actually think that's less
helpful i can hire somebody down the
street to do that
yeah it's more about investment and
we're on the same team not a fourth kid
that just will do whatever you say right
um
so
a couple of things here first is
my guest with three little kids
what you just explained about being at
home alone a lot him gone a lot your
marriage is
is
there's some there's some stress on it
right now is that fair
that's fair yeah okay
so
one of the this is gonna be i don't this
be controversial people gonna give put
mean comments about me and that's fine
i'm right
one of the key anchors for your son is
gonna be
mom and dad like each other
mom and dad are connected i can anchor
into that and if i don't feel safe then
my body reacts to something's not right
and my guess is when you're anchored
into him
you are a little bit more
and when he's anchored into you he may
be a little more perceptive or maybe a
little more connected
and i know it sounds weird you called me
about rage and i'm talking about your
marriage
but that radioactivity spreads
throughout your house
and then you feel it he feels it he's
going to step away he's going to come
home a little bit later
you're going to get a little bit more
angry and then each one of your kids is
going to have a different response based
on what they learned what their genetic
wiring is and all that's going to play
into their response
see how it's a system that we're talking
about not just an an incident
yep yeah
so
what i would love for you to do is this
and very few couples will do this and it
would save marriages it not only saved
marriages that sounds so dramatic it
just gives people a better life
is i want you and your husband to get a
babysitter even if you can't afford it
get one
and you all go redesign your life now
that you got three kids you probably did
a lot of dreaming and thinking about
what life was gonna be before kid won
was kid one on purpose or an accident
on purpose oh yeah each of them so you
planned for that one and then now all of
a sudden it's just adequate attitude and
now every single part of your life is
different and if you don't stop and
acknowledge it and say man we just
remember we used to have fun we used to
just make out all the time and now i'm
just got poop on me and you're you're
working
you've got to say those things out loud
and acknowledge them and then say that
that creates a space where y'all can
safely talk to one another and he can
say
i don't know how to say this but
i miss sex and you're gonna be like your
first thought's gonna be like i'm
cleaning crap off and you're gonna go i
miss you too and then you can say
i really
need you to be invested i need your
ideas around here i need your support i
need you to feel like you're not just a
fourth kid and here's what that could
look like and you're creating a context
where you all can safely talk to one
another is that fair
yep yeah and then we get to your little
one
if you have moments where you burst and
i want you to really be careful about
yelling okay
if you do
i want you to go to your six-year-old
and look him in the eye get down at his
eye level you go to him
and say mommy should not have yelled and
i'm sorry and i want you to hug him
because yelling for a little kid is is
fear it's a it's it triggers a fear
response and then they act
out of a response they're not acting out
of their
cognitive part of their brain okay and i
want you to do the last thing and this
after you all you and your husband have
your meeting together i want you've
probably heard me talk about this on the
show i want you to create a family
values chart and bring that six-year-old
along not the three-year-old and not the
eight-month-old but the six-year-old
and i want him to know
he is a cornerstone of this family now
he's six i know but
he gets to be invested in this thing and
he gets to pick some things like when
your husband says we are people who
laugh i want your son to add one we are
people who
uh wha whatever your last name is the
smiths the smiths are people who
don't yell
and then he'll look at you and you can
say i know mommy yells but mommy's going
to
stop
is going to work on not yelling anymore
so what mommy does yell i want you to
you you get to i don't know you get to
point at me and you get to say no
yelling mommy right whatever the thing
is
yeah
as a part of that
we do not throw fits
we use our words not our hands
and when that happens
when he throws a fit when he goes into
one of his rages
then he is opting out of
being with you guys
not you're kicking him away not you're
hitting him not that you're sending him
you are out of my presence you've done a
thing that you can't be with me
it is oh my goodness you opted out by
acting like this
and what he'll learn in short order that
using his words is better than the new
it's a it serves as a release valve for
lack of better terms for his rage
and really in rage as a kid is i feel
trapped i've got all these emotions i
miss my mom i don't know why there's so
much tension in this house why is this
eight-month-old getting more attention
than me i used to be the only one i
don't have any words for that and so i
just smash stuff
and he needs to learn that that behavior
is his choice to opt out and so he's
going to learn new behavior so he will
stay plugged in because that's really
the root of all of this is he wants to
be reconnected to everybody is that fair
yep yeah it sounds like a lot and it's
it's not it's
it's a planning session a grieving
session of what was planning session of
what is to come with you and your
husband getting on the same page about
family values i need you i need you
and then it's going to be about bringing
the six-year-old along and letting them
know he's a part of this thing which
means he's got some responsibility
and then last one
if you feel like you're gonna yell come
up with a system that somebody you can
call that you can step away
plan i don't know what your financial
situation is but plan for
some time just for you to get out of the
house that's a lot three little ones
there's a lot a lot especially in cove
and all the lockdowns and all the crazy
that's a lot on you and i want you to
take care of yourself
yep are you doing okay
yeah i am i think i need to do better at
that though for sure take away the needs
and take and and i want you to say like
i need to do this because it just
becomes a chore and then you get annoyed
at you because you have to take care of
you
right instead of saying i need to do
this i want you to say i get to i
deserve to
yeah fair
yes you my friend ellen
you are
worth taking care of yourself and i'll
tell you this your kids can't be okay
unless you're okay so i want you to work
on you too
and for most of us i don't know it
starts with our marriage
i wish it wasn't the case i wish we
could buy into the nonsense we've got
the last 100 years which i just need to
be me bro and then
we'll all come together so how that
works
we got to come together together
come together together that sounded
stupid we'll be right back on the dr
john dolan show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john deloney show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john dolone show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
hey what's up we are back
i cannot tell you
how nervous i am how excited i am that
finally after man it feels like a year
and a half of work on this deal my new
book own your past change your future is
now in pre-sale
you can get you can you can pick up uh
you can go to john delaney.com you can't
pick it up yet you go to johnlon.com
and pick up
i keep saying pick up james you can't
pick it up yet you can order it
pre-sale and it comes with hundreds of
dollars of of pre-sale stuff that's
gonna come with it for free
it
guys i'm real excited about this in this
book i'm going to walk through a common
sense approach i think we've over
over sensationalized and over
complicated what being well is what
mental health is and in the book i
unpack
a number of stories
just
wildness that we've been told is normal
that we've been told is the
quote-unquote way to do stuff
and when we feel that gap between what
our life actually is and what we're
supposed to be doing
our brain sounds the alarm our body
sounds the alarms
and
man
over the next over the next
i don't know 12 weeks i'm going to
unpack some of these stories
and we're going to take particular calls
over the last year i've taken some so
many of these same calls we've gotten so
many emails that i incorporated them
into the book you are a part of this
book listeners you all are a part of
this thing
and so we're going to take calls related
to different aspects of the book
um so we can i can show you guys how
we're all living this mad world and
there's a
simple it's ancient
path out of this thing
it's
really simple and it's really hard but
we can all do it right so go to
johndaloni.com hey by the way you get
the free audiobook you get the free
ebook you get a free month of counseling
and better help other stuff go to
johndelaney.com and pre-order the book
own your past change your future right
now all right let's go to ryan in denver
hey ryan what's up brother
dr d it's good to talk to you how are
you sir good it's good to talk to you my
brother so what's up dude
well i kind of got a long-term problem
that
needs some help and needs some work
through um
three years ago i had my second child
he's uh
he has a disability
which causes him not to be able to walk
very well
i would say that he can get around on
flat hard surfaces but that's the limit
of his ability
and
as a kid myself i was super into sports
super into physical activities um
and my dad was right there with me and
going into our adult lives
we
we just kept it going i mean we
we've run marathons together we hike
mountains together we've remodeled our
houses like a good saturday afternoon is
ripping out the chainsaws and getting
after it like that is a good way to
spend time with my dad
and
and looking at my son
and looking at our relationship
i have
a deep-seated fear and i would even say
that it is into resentment that i will
not have that same experience with my
son
and
i don't know what fatherhood would like
a healthy father-son relationship looks
like
if it doesn't include all of these
physical things
um i
like i'm not afraid to learn that i'm
not afraid to understand what that means
and unpackage it
but
i'm i'm mad at the universe
yeah that we're in this situation
i'm really sad
i have some resentment i have some fear
and i
i don't want that to poison our
relationship because he's a good kid
he's an awesome like dr d he's an
awesome kid he's an awesome kid
and i love the kid to pieces
but
but i don't know what the future looks
like
with a kid like that
dude and a guy like me i i i can't tell
you
where did you where did you learn that
language
uh yeah i learned that from my father
okay dude
i i'm saying like
your ability
to articulate how you feel
is
is reminiscent of someone who's done
some extensive counseling
or
has an extraordinary father
well we've done both okay all right okay
um
your ability to parse through i'm both
angry
and i here's where my anger is directed
at our future relationship was which is
a separate entity man it takes months to
get people to realize you're not mad at
her you're mad at what is right at the
relationship yeah that's so hard and
you're already there
that you can articulate anger and
resentment and sadness
dude you're way down the road i want to
tell you you're a brave guy because
here's why
most guys would not say out loud what
you just said
and they bottle that stuff up
and it poisons everyone including
themself and they die young
and they rob everybody of relationship
of safety of feeling loved and you're
not doing that
and you're maybe one of the more honest
people i've talked to in the last few
months and i'm grateful for you
it's awesome
now
you've said the right words
i don't get a sense that you have felt
them yet
no
not really i feel like if you felt them
it would be overwhelming in a way that
you might not that you don't feel like
you're ready for
yeah i i would say when i look at the
landscape of my life
i can see it over there
it's just over there yeah
but it's not right here yet
why not i would say like what are you
scared about honestly
so
the reason why it's not here is because
he's three and he's surrounded by
three-year-olds and his disability is
hidden by the fact that none of the kids
are super
super physical either
like nobody is running and jumping and
nobody like they run and they jump but
but it's close enough that it doesn't
look that different so it's not here yet
and he's got a younger sister and he's
still way more mobile than she is
but today when she surpasses him i think
is when it's going to really hit
and that's going to be the big day
um so here's here's what you're doing
right now
you love that little boy
and you
can i be real hard is that cool
you remember
the way you used to look at boys like
that when you were a kid
yeah and you remember the way you and
your buddies made jokes about people i
was there too
until my very best friend on planet
earth
was in a life-altering car wreck and
he's unable to move most of his body now
and that was 25 years ago
and then i spent the last 20 years
working with people with all different
kinds of special needs whether mobility
challenges or able body challenges or or
cognitive challenges and it re-changed
my life but i had to go through a serie
a season of grieving who i used to be
because i used to suck
because like you i thought every kid
should run fast and i was a high school
hero athlete and me and my dad played
you know what i mean
i wasn't true exactly i know exactly
what you mean and so you're gonna have
to go through a period of
forgiving yourself
and say i'm sorry
and then
the other thing you're doing is you love
this little boy so much
you are
casting into the future
how bad his life might be and you're
trying to
trying to protect him from those things
you're going to rob yourself of
your current relationship always
anticipating future hurts let's be
honest kids are gonna make fun of them
cause kids suck they just do
yeah and
he's gonna have periods of grief where
he wishes he could run and kick a ball
too
and that's gonna suck
and
y'all are gonna find some things that
y'all do together that no other dad and
son do
and you grew up with a dad who was hyper
intentional about loving you
demonstrably he showed you love he
didn't just talk about it
and i have every belief in my
every bone i have in my body that you're
gonna figure that out whether that
you're gonna be the greatest call of
duty dad of all time that game sucks
don't play that but what you're gonna be
the greatest whatever guy of all time or
you're gonna figure out how to take him
hunting with it some
cool there's some great opportunities to
there's all kinds of stuff y'all you're
gonna figure it out
but you got to get past your
self-forgiveness you got to get past
catastrophizing his future for him and
there's even probably a part of you
that's looked at one day you're going to
die and then who's going to be there to
protect him
yeah
and
have you already been there
been there done that okay yep the trust
fund is being funded as we speak there
you go
here's here's more important than your
money here's more important than your
money that's future
more important than your money
is you create a young man who freaking
loves himself
who is scared of nothing
who is able to go that sucks and that
really hurts and i'm moving on
who learns the same words that you've
learned i'm angry i'm resentful i am sad
i'm heartbroken
and then you make him bulletproof you
make him anti-fragile to quote to lab
you make him into somebody that when
people are on top of it like yeah just
keep doubting me dude keep doubting me
and watch what happens
i will write a program on this computer
code that will
that my my futuristic house will eat
your future i don't know what that's
going to look like in 100 years but you
know what i mean
you create a young man who is able to
face all challenges not who has every
challenge cleared ahead of him
and
you're just on a different path brother
and it's gonna be magical but it starts
with you looking in the mirror and
saying i'm sorry and
i'm gonna be the greatest dad this that
has ever existed
and i also want to back up for 30
seconds
dude we've been cast into this story
that family is supposed to look a
certain way
and some of that picture comes from what
we were born into right two and a half
kids and half of a dog and two cars
two suvs in a house right like
if we don't have that
and it could be that our parents got
divorced or we have three sisters and
one brother whatever it looks like
there's a part of our brain that tries
to solve for that picture
and then the second complicating layer
is a story you were told you were told a
really beautiful story about what father
and son relationship looks like
it's ball games chainsaws fixing crap
talking crap you know what it's it's
it's
that's that's what father's son is
so you've got these two pictures in your
head
and then you've got this beautiful
little boy
with some different kind of challenges
he's gonna have some different kind of
awesomeness too but he's got some
challenges
and your brain is trying to solve for
those two pictures and i want you to own
those two pictures and i want you to
grieve the fact that they're not yours
and then dude your brain will go oh cool
looks like ryan's back in control i'm
gonna stop reacting and then you get to
solve for you get to you get to create
what the future looks like
is it is that ringing a bell with you
does that feel right no that that is
perfect you know solve for future
yeah dude solve it solve for freedom
it's all for a future dude solve for
more laughter than you think your body
can handle
yeah i like that plan solve for a future
where your son
dude is able to make jokes faster than
anybody else at the table he's also able
to say
hey
that's parking spot is for me
and just so you know my buddy's a
paraplegic and we
hassle him
dude to the point it is brutal and he
hassles us back
and it is yeah gnarly right
and i'll never forget the meeting and if
i don't if i talk about show i never
forget when he was in the hospital and
we thought he was going to die and then
they said well he might make it but if
he makes it he's going to have some
massive cognitive and mobility
challenges
and me and his little brother and one of
our other close friends chris we sat in
a in like a denny's or something in the
middle of the night while he we've been
sleeping on the floor in the icu for
several nights and
we said hey
how are we gonna treat him
like are we gonna change everything up
and all of a sudden no
if he makes it out of this thing we're
gonna make fun of him like we always did
and he's gonna make fun of us and i want
you to know i'm telling you that because
of this
he's going to have friends in his life
that will love him and razz him and
protect him because that's what friends
do
and it's just going to look different
right
indifferent isn't broken different is it
wrong difference just different
yeah all right so i threw a lot at you
feels different come back to me
yeah no that's uh that's a whole bunch
i'm gonna have to listen to this on the
podcast a couple of times okay i'm gonna
be on packaging that for a while but no
i i
yeah got a little bit of soul
forgiveness to do yes was i right there
i used to be was that right
yeah and i wouldn't say never i was
never mean and i was never cruel but i
was
i was a little you know
a bit of a turd i wasn't mean or cruel
either i maybe once or twice i was just
an idiot
but i was i i didn't know that doesn't i
do this doesn't make it
that's exactly it i got a blind spot
that's it
after you said that i was like you know
what
we're gonna have to spend some time
working through that because
i'm gonna have to grieve that part of me
and then i'm gonna have to forgive that
part of me yeah so that i can be a
better future for this little munchkin i
believe that that many of us millions
and millions of us know the world's
screwed up and we also know
i could fill in the blank with any group
you want to
people with special needs people it feel
in the blank
we know that we could treat different
groups of people better
or more right or we could say i'm sorry
but when we do that we have to look in
our rear view mirror that the wake of
people we've either hurt intentionally
or unknowing i didn't know that joke was
i didn't know that joke hurt like that i
was trying to be funny you know what i
mean i was a 14 year old kid i didn't i
didn't know i was 25 i didn't know
we have to look in our rearview mirror
at the wake of people we've run over
and say i'm so sorry
i'll start doing better today and i'm
like you i wasn't like just finding
students with special needs and being
ugly i just didn't notice
yeah and i just went through my life as
though
everyone should be 62 195 and be able to
run this fast i just that's called
privilege right it's called i didn't
know and now i do
and now i make sure nobody
in my presence doesn't know that i love
them
and i think they're doing a great job
or uh like zach back there i could make
fun of zachary
zach's incredible all right but
here i'm saying
yep now i'm not ever gonna but no i
learned and i'm gonna do better and i'm
gonna forgive myself for what was and
i'm gonna go be about what is
and your son hear me say
one
the
lottery with you as his dad
well we're not sure about that yet no no
we're not we're gonna we gotta we gotta
we gotta land that listen the fact that
you're even engaging this conversation
puts you in the
rare rare air
top one percent of one percent
and then it's going to be about action
after this
yeah the action is the uh
we're going to be unpackaging that for
about a lifetime that's kind of i think
the yeah the point
you're going to recognize oh this is i'm
projecting fear into the future here and
we're here right now
yeah yep i might have a heart attack and
he might have to figure out how to get
um an electronic wheelchair
and
that's a problem for future us
what i can do right now is put money
into that trust i can teach him how to
speak for himself and i can whip his
butt at minecraft i don't even know if
you whip somebody's butt at minecraft
i know mike tyson's punch-out super
mario brothers but
you hear what i'm saying
i do acknowledge it call it out the
stories you were born into the stories
you were told they're good stories and
they're fine but they're not reality and
now it's about living into that reality
god ryan you've i i can't tell you i'm
not just saying blowing smoke at you
the fact that you're asking these
questions and articulating it in this
way
last little tip stay out of resentment
when you feel yourself in entering into
resentment write a journal in fact you
want to be a super dad start a journal
and give it to him someday with that
that's the goal he's three right now
start a journal with here's how much i
love you here's how much i'm scared
about your future
[Music]
i i'm gonna miss playing ball with you
but i'm gonna learn how to play the
cello or i'm gonna learn how to play
video games or i'm gonna learn how to do
do whatever you think is awesome
i'm gonna figure out a way for us to
play catch with the football even though
you're not right i want you to keep a
journal on that stuff when are you gonna
give it to him
and he's gonna have a
10-year 20-year 30-year 40-year
arc of just how much his dad loved him
i can think of
literally
no better gift
man
we'll be right back in the dr john de
luna show
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan two hundred trust me that's triple
eight loan two hundred
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
one five nine one in the miles consumer
access dot org equal housing lender 1749
mallory lane sweet 100 brentwood
tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and are not available in
all states or locations
all right we are back before we take the
last call
man i'm still
still buzzing from that last call i love
i love the call of ryan and his heart um
one thing that is in
that we talk about in this book in my
new book on your past change of future
is
this like changing picture of family
this our obsession with
what families are quote unquote supposed
to look like the quote unquote right way
to do it
the in and so much of that is
40 years old
50 years old 100 years old
and this idea that
we have to have a white pick of fence
and a house that looks like this and
two and a half kids and a dog and what
somehow that just became part of our
cultural mythology
and if you have a family that looks
different than that and by the way
almost all of us do
almost all of us do
our brains solve for that former picture
because it's trying to get back to
equilibrium trying to get back to what's
quote unquote normal what's right
and so we have to look at that our
changing picture of family and say this
is what i've got
i've got three grandparents living with
me my dad passed away young
mom's on her third husband i whatever it
happens to be this is the cards i was
dealt this is my world how can i be well
find joy find peace
how can i learn patience and kindness
and strength and resilience and
discipline in this context
the stories of our families have changed
so fast
and we're all living in an old picture
and even further as ryan described it
the stories were told about our families
this is all we are the delonies are
people who fill in the blank we're just
yellers we're just angry we just don't
handle money well we just eat too much
bullcrap to all that
the story you were told about family
story you're told about your family can
change
you can write something new you can
paint a different picture
remember that the stories you were born
into in the stories you were told in
this changing picture of family so thank
you so that's some of the stuff we
talked about in the book ma'am and ryan
did a great job of
just articulating gosh man what a gift
awesome all right take one more call
it's good emily in atlanta georgia hey
emily what's up
hi dr john how are you i'm good how are
you
i'm well thank you excellent what's up
how can i help
okay so um
my question is how do i keep my marriage
like fun and silly spontaneous and
whatnot
um when
those were a bunch of words for sexy is
am i am i right okay all right how do
you keep your marriage sexy when
um
when my husband is constantly making
jokes or innuendos that make me
feel uncomfortable because my kids are
around
gross
why does he do that
um our kids are really young we have
three kids two and under okay um
and so i think
i think it stems from because
while before we had kids i mean
we just lived on our own and it was you
know two years ago we could say whatever
we wanted whenever we wanted yeah but
now i think my husband still lives in
that that our kids don't understand
um
but i guess i have a
fear that because we have all boys that
they are going to pick up on this and
think it's okay to treat women in a way
that makes them feel uncomfortable
um
or
you know
make comments about what they're wearing
and
not understand that that's just not what
i'm allowed to do because i'm a man or
something like that gotcha um
and so i've i've explained this to my
husband and so it seems like it's a
roller coaster like he'll do better for
a little while and then he'll
kind of revisit this behavior so to
speak where i'm like dude i want to be
comfortable in my house like and i'm not
comfortable making these jokes around my
my kids um even though they're not
receptive to it now i just think that
one day they will be sure and i'm afraid
that this problem so to speak won't be
handled by then and then it feels like
it will be too late that this will be
ingrained in them okay
so let me ask you a few clarifying
questions number one thanks for
articulating that uh
there's a lot there um
before you had kids
yes
if he told you something that he saw
thought you were sexy or you wore
something and he's like man
like
i got five minutes if you got five like
he he he was in it did you like that or
i mean was that something that was
attractive to you you liked being your
husband thinking you were sexy and and
wanting to be with you or did that make
you uncomfortable then
at that point at me i was fine with that
i was okay with it because it was rare
not finding that not finding okay
like didn't yeah i was i was comfortable
with it like i accepted it i liked it
okay okay that's well received okay so
well
what i'm getting at is was it something
that you just tolerated that's his weird
thing that he likes to and
was that a weird yeah you tolerated a a
strange sexual perversion he has and
it's not but i'm just just go with my
language there right
or did you like no it was awesome i like
being recognized no yeah it was awesome
it was rare then because before we had
kids my husband he's a reserved person
as it is so it's
it was rare then it seems like it's
amped up since we've had kids and maybe
it's because
um
like we're not able to have sex with
officers yeah there you go that's
exactly where i was headed so
so he had a thing
that
worked
when he used it
and the work in his head and again he's
not here to defend himself so i'm just
getting inside of his head which is the
thing i tell people never to do but this
is a radio show here we go um
is he knows he had one thing or maybe
two things or whatever who knows
that
would make your eyes squint a little bit
right
and
now
you're you'll have two little you have
two little ones right how old
no we have three little ones we have
one that's almost a year and then we
have two
twin boys that are almost three years
oh my gosh y'all y'all are probably
getting close to the the bi-annual sex
plan right now with three little kids
right
oh yes so you've got three tiny ones
and you've got a husband who misses you
yeah and we can we can say it's about
set he misses you
right
and of course there's sexuality and all
that but he misses intimacy with his
wife and so yeah now he's doubling down
on the only thing he knows
here's the conversation that has to
happen and you you did man i'm proud of
you first first question i always ask in
these situations is have you actually
told them and you have which is great
um
i i think what the conversation you'll
have to have is a deeper one
because it's not just about the comments
because the comments are he's only got
one path
to connection with you to intimate
connection with you right to sex
right the path below that is
oh my gosh we have three little kids
what's happening a to our marriage
b
like
how do we re-engage intimacy into this
and it's not
through you telling me making sexualized
jokes about my body
in front of my three little kids that's
the least sexy with
the last way to get me in bed is this
yes
what you are going to have to think
through is what does
what is a an environment that he can
help create
that would allow you to feel sexy again
okay
so you tell me what are a couple of
things
let me back emily nagaski says the off's
off and the ons on and i love that
what are the things that turn this
environment into a
hotter environment for lack of better
terms and what are the things that make
it cold
i think and i've talked on the show
having dishes in the sink for some
reason
makes my wife
i'm out
i've got to get that done before and you
know what i mean
and then there's other things that i'm
like i'm out and vice versa right so i
know now i just i'm going to make sure
the dishes are the same
just i'm just gonna make sure that's a
part of my life right what are some
things that would be ons for you
environmentalists
kids asleep yeah
um
um yeah cleaned up after dinner after
the day have all the toys away
and
probably a clean bedroom
so that there's nothing to think about
other than what's going on not like the
laundry sitting in the corner or
something you know like that those are
probably the top three just clean house
all together
clean space
for sexual activity and then the kid's
asleep
what does it what does he do for a
living
my husband's in the air force air force
okay
is he a pilot what does he do
no he's um security forces okay so let's
let's pretend he's a pilot this may be a
good analogy
you have to make sure that plane has
been checked over
is all the electronics are working all
the systems are working all the radars
and all that stuff's working and the
cockpit has to be clean because those
things are there's a tight space there
right they have to be clean they have to
be spotless
and then somebody's gonna get in that
thing and fly that plane
right
and so
he's got to know that there's an
environment here
and if you sit down and say hey
i need you to know
like nothing makes me more out of the
mood
than looking over and seeing my three
little boys watch you
talk to me about my body
okay but
here's what super would get me in the
mood
if you would take bedtimes
three nights a week
if when you walk in the door i know
you're tired
but if you just did a scan of this
living room and made sure the toys were
up
if i'm taking a shower after the kids
are in bed
if you would just run through this
bedroom
and make sure it's picked up
i'm gonna rock your ever-loving world
right
and
here's the thing for you
is when we get out of step with intimacy
i wish there was another way to say this
because it sounds so perfunctory but
we have to practice our way back into
intimacy and practice our way back into
desire
and that means you have to know
i i may not be interested right now but
if we get going i'm gonna love this
right okay and so it's it's you
practicing it's him practicing it's you
being very clear here's here's the offs
for me
and here are the ons and the ons are
simple you don't even have to say
anything about my body anymore i know
i'm smoking hot you married me let's
move past that the kids don't need to
know that
and here's what would really help out it
would free my soul to be all about you
and not all about this and this and this
and this and this and this and this and
this
and dude you'll be giving him the
greatest gift
any spouse could give their their their
other partner and that's clarity and a
path to me
okay
i do have one question without my
husband is is really great about
helping out taking i'm definitely in
this season of life i'm definitely a
like a
an acts of service love language
receiver and so
he's really awesome about doing that
already
and
i know you had mentioned that i'm going
to have to practice getting back into
intimacy and whatnot
but what about the times that he does
all those things and that it's still
just a no from me because i feel like
all those things can be done but it
still could have been a really tough day
with the kids because i'm at home with
them all day long um
and i'm just like
no and that's like five days in a row
because they are long tough days yeah
is there a
so one totally honor that totally get
that
is there a way that you find rest and
release
through that with him or no
and not really
and
it's important for you to be honest
about that
right because some of that may be
hormonal and i've told them yeah and so
that may be hormonal some of that may be
just seasoned right now
some of that may be
there's a hundred different reasons why
that might be right yeah um
when you get going
are you glad that you got going or no is
it still a chore all the way through
depends on the
depends on the time
i would say like 50 50. like half the
time i'm like let's get this over with
and then another half of the time i'm
like all right i'm here like this is
great what are the what are the what are
the differences in those two
um
the difference is i would say i
and not to cite my husband he's a
wonderful guy but sometimes i just feel
like he comes to me like a teenage boy
and whatnot and i'm like
okay yeah let's just get this over with
so that you can leave me alone for three
nights
we can revisit this when things start
peaking again for you and i'll just deal
with it then um and part of that is like
i'm
i'm the emotional regulator for three
little ones and myself all day long and
so i'm like you come to me like this and
even though you've done all the things
the cleaning of the house or just
whatever all those things are done or
we've taken care of them together and
whatnot it's like i feel like i'm back
to emotionally regulating
for somebody else and i don't want to do
that
at the end of my day i want to like
sit down and just do or take care of the
things that need to be taken care of and
whatnot
there's a lot of me that's like you deal
with you and i'll deal with me and then
we can just come together and i know
that's awful but it just feels like some
nights that's what it is and i can't
so i'm just like
emily i want to give you
a brief pass for a second
you have two three-year-olds and a
one-year-old
yeah
this isn't forever
yeah this is a season
okay
and
there is
this level i i know you've talked to him
have you ever said that what you just
said
yeah i've said that before
have you given him another way another
path to you that's not a middle school
boy or a high school boy
like have you articulated what that
means
i've articulated that i feel like
um well
i've said it in different ways but it
all kind of leads back to that okay i
want you to think about it and think
about the clarity there because when you
say hey i feel like you're just coming
at me like a middle school boy
my guess is again he's not here to
defend himself my guess is he's thinking
this is how we've always interacted
i've always told you that i'd think of
nothing but you and i want you and you
were all into that and now it's shifted
and suddenly he's feeling chastised for
the way y'all used to communicate
and so
it's not that the way you feel is wrong
the way you feel is right it's the way
you feel
and i'll say the way that he used to
come at you was how what you loved it's
about developing a new way
and so by just by saying hey
this is no good anymore which is
not only fine it's beautiful it's we go
all of us shift and change throughout
our marriage it's great
but it's what's the next path and i love
to hear you say
no sometimes it's all in sometimes
there's things about the way he comes at
me or the way we end up together that
are incredible
and other times they're not other times
i feel like he's just being a middle
school boy and i'm just some girl on the
playground and it's being able to say
this is what made this
completely on and this is what made this
off
okay and he's gonna have to practice new
ways of
coming at his wife
yeah and you are gonna have to give
yourself some grace sister because
you got two three-year-olds and a
one-year-old yeah
everything is bananas
and
contin
expect your desire to be low cause your
body is taking care of three other
humans and in some ways it sounds like a
fourth human too
emotionally
give yourself some space and some peace
there and
remember he's practicing in a new way of
coming at his wife and he needs your
help for clarification what what are
ways
that best bring him to you and
you're gonna get back into practicing
desire and desire is gonna look
different now like you say when we were
young and married and he would come home
smoking out air force guy it was on like
d kong and now it's different because we
got three little ones
right okay is it fair
yeah that and that all sounds exactly
right but he is just doing what he's
always practiced and i'm not giving him
like clear another clear path so
and he might come and say occasionally
i want to pretend like we're in college
again
yeah
and that will be his weird little
college fantasy and then you can decide
whether you're in on that one or not
right we all everyone in the world's got
like what if we uh
you know whatever um and so
every couple's got those kind of things
to navigate and work through
but
this is the moment when couples go oh
this is going to be the rest of our
lives we're falling apart things are
broken this is going to be it forever
and
it's not
it's just a small season
just a small season
i love that you have these conversations
i love it i love it i love it i love it
i love it
the the
the future for your marriage is bright
to be honest with them and always looks
to create new paths towards each other
because the old paths don't always work
anymore hey we'll be right back on the
dr john delaney show
big secret almost all of us can control
our thoughts
yes you can control your thoughts you
choose them most people believe thoughts
randomly happen and that we have to give
rent-free space to bad thoughts and
scary thoughts and freaky thoughts this
is not true
our world doesn't want you to know this
because they want the privilege of
owning your mind no more i want to teach
you how to take back your thoughts
if you often find yourself lost in a
tornado of toxic thoughts and anxiety
and always on high alert you'll have to
be intentional about changing your
thoughts but it is 100
possible in my new book own your past
change your future we'll walk through a
not so complicated approach to mental
health and wellness that includes
learning how to reject harmful thoughts
and cultivate thoughts that move you
closer to who you want to be
and if you pre-order today you'll get
hundreds of dollars of free bonus items
so go to johndaloni.com to take the next
step towards wellness that's own your
past change your future at
johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
don't forget go to john dolan dot com
pick up my new book and dude i know i
sound all like sales mini
uh uh and there's one of the things
about this show is like i never went to
one of those sales many shows cannot
stand like slickster like yeah
can't stand that
but i really in my bones believe this
book is going to help
people live better lives i really do go
to john dealer.com own your past change
your future
you got to deal with what happened to
you and you gotta be about what's next
go to johnnyland.com and check it out
all right as we wrap up today's show
song of the day one of my favorite bands
of all time and i know i share this with
my main man zach the killers dude
these guys are smoking the song's called
when we were young and it goes like this
you sit there in your heartache i love
this song waiting on some beautiful boy
to save you from your old ways to play
forgiveness watch it now here he comes
he doesn't look a thing like jesus but
he talks like a gentleman like you
imagined when you were young
can we climb this mountain i don't know
higher now than ever before i know we
can make it if we take it slow let's
take it easy easy now watch it go
we're burning down the highway skyline
on the back of a hurricane that started
turning
when you were young
god i love those guys man when you were
young right here on the doctor john
owens show
you